hi folks my name is Barbara I'm only
here to introduce our very own speaker
and then I'm going to hang around to to
answer questions if you're going to have
any um I hope you all got a chance to
join the opening sessions uh session a
few hours ago let by Camila who's also
on this call uh if not all the recording
is going to be available for everyone's
use in a short time I also wanted to
encourage you to use our slack Channel
if you have any question questions or
are if you Keen to start up a discussion
after the
session and for today we have John star
is already present he's a manager he's a
program manager for open source science
initiatives um and he has a very
intriguing uh topic of his of his talk
today head first no foot first on a
second top I'll sit on the edge of the
pool and let my feet dangle um
intriguing I'm curious to see where it's
going to take us John you got 30 minutes
uh to start your chat but if you need a
little bit more time you're welcome to
continue folks if you can join past that
time you're also welcome to to stick
around otherwise you will be able to
access the recording afterward uh just a
brief remind about a code of conduct all
of us have access to it in a intro email
sent um with the invitees to those
sessions John floor is yours thanks P
I'm also interested to see where this
takes us um
so uh I am uh going to share my story in
open source because I've been doing this
for 10 years that was my thinking at
least share my journey through open
source up to being program manager of
OSI uh but I am very open to having an
engagement with anyone who's here so if
you want to talk about something or if
you want me to talk about something
specifically uh that I touch on throw it
in the chat or feel free to raise your
hand and unmute happy to talk talk here
um and then I'll share this if you ever
want to reach out to me for anything
feel free uh this QR code will take you
to some very OSI open source science
initiative uh specific links but my
email is just right down here feel free
to email me about anything happy to
talk yeah let's see open source so like
I said I've been doing this for 10 years
a little more at this point I got into
it um in terms of contributing in
2013 but when I'm thinking back to
it
uh I participated in open source
projects in like the early 2000s or
would would become open source projects
if any of you remember seti at home uh
where you would put like this this cool
screen saver up and your computer would
try to search for aliens for extra trust
real life and it would look really
really neat and was really engaging a
lot of fun uh that was turned into an
open source project called the Berkeley
open infrastructure for network
computing uh and that would like I did
that as a kid my parents put it on the
computer it's a lot of fun um but
eventually like 10 years after doing
that as a child uh I turned around and
started to become a contributor to boink
um and disclosure here I don't code at
all I cannot code to save my life um
well GPT now helps with that a little
bit but so if I don't code how do I
start contributing to an open- Source uh
project particularly one as complex and
Tech heavy as boink uh for those who
don't know um berthy open infrastructure
for network computing giant distributed
computing infrastructure that's
permissionless anyone can log on like
set a distributed computing project up
and then send out what called work units
across this giant it's essentially a
giant supercomputer it's in the top 20
uh or top 30 most uh powerful
supercomputers in the world when you add
up the flops um and people institutions
individuals universities use around the
world it's a very technical project
um but I am not a technical person so I
get in there and I start trying to
organize Community around it at the same
time I'm not a technical person and this
is a very technical project so you get
in there and there's a lot of people who
are very technical people obviously and
it's very int intimidating so one of the
first things I did was try to get
involved and then kind of backed off
right that's kind of where that hey I'm
just gonna Dive Right In first and then
on second thought maybe I I'll just see
what it's like in there uh before going
in so it it's this experience I had with
boink which I still contribute to I
ended up um creating communities and
ultimately nonprofit out of it I'll talk
about in a second but the the intro
experience is was very rough and I don't
think that is unusual for a lot of
people getting into open source um so
for anyone new to open
source uh I would that that would kind
of be a piece of advice expect to be
uncomfortable when you first jump in and
if you're not uncomfortable when you
first jump in oh man you had a great
experience appreciate that and if you
have these thoughts of like hey maybe
this is what I want to
do uh try to work through them because
you're probably not the first person to
have those thoughts because it is a very
different world versus going to
University and then going out and going
to corporate space something that helped
me stick with it particularly with boink
which you again very specific very
technical community which is an amazing
Community once you're part of it once
you get into it and start know what's
going on uh but one thing that helped me
is I really knew what I wanted to do and
I wanted to contribute to science I
wanted to make science bigger better
faster engaging more engaging for the
public inclusive more inclusive um and
boink was a very uh direct way to
achieving those personal goals of mine
which ties into what open source is at
the root of it is is developing software
uh for your own personal needs I'm just
not developing software I'm developing
communities um and other sort of
resources I'll get into
but because I had that personal drive it
wasn't about upskilling to a job it
wasn't about uh learning a new thing it
was about proactively contributing to
something I thought was meaningful I
kept going I did step back a little bit
and look take a a wider look at what was
going on but eventually all those other
things did happen I did gain skills that
I use today at my job at num Focus um
and and I've built a great Professional
Network out of all this open source
engagement and open source participation
but I wasn't contributing to do those
things I was contributing to do
something I love
um yeah so this is ultimately where I
got into open source and still stick
around and some of these things that
resulted out of just wanting to build
community and building resources um for
example uh I created a podcast with a
friend from Australia who I still talked
to who still friends with in fact him
and I and uh five other people
co-founded this nonprofit called the
science comments initiative where we
eventually we founded this what two or
three years ago but we had known each
other since like 2013 14 15 16 17 we met
people along the way um is a nonprofit
looking to use open source software and
Technology to engage the public in
science and it's just another way to
cont continue contributing to something
that I find very interesting very
important which is improving science
again making it faster making it more
inclusive and uh making the public part
of the scientific
process uh and the people who are part
of this are wonderful people who I've
known for many years now and have a very
wide
background come from very different
places uh and so that has been very fun
to be a part of and if I had
when I first started participating in
boing if I had just stopped instead of
just like taking a step back I would
have never met these people I would have
never uh make a nonprofit that I think
is really starting to make an impact
like one of the initiatives we're
working on right now is bringing boink
this giant permissionless infrastructure
into high schools uh grade schools
essentially anything pre col college for
those of you not in the US um
and that's going to be really fun we can
get kids excited about science in the
same way that I got excited about
science through set at home by looking
for aliens on my on my screen saber um
and again none of that would have
happened if I had just stopped versus
just taken a step back and and moving a
little slower um I wish it would have
been I could just Dive Right In and
start doing some really cool stuff right
away but this is not necessarily how
open source Works um one of the other
things that came out of my participation
with blink is another open- source
project this is part of a world that
some people are not uh super
enthusiastic about but I'm super
passionate about
economics and this is a way I can
contribute to both science and economics
and it is just another open- source
project that is built on top of boink um
where if I had never contributed to
boink in that first place I would never
have found people who are doing other
stuff with this open source tool that I
found so engaging so now this is a whole
another thing building communities still
doing what I'm good at still learning
different skills along the way uh like
for example I ended up writing the white
paper for this
twice but it's a very long technical not
technical it's like between super
technical documentation and a abstract
of a project so in order to write this
this thing I had to communicate with
developers and project organizers and
mechanism designers and learn develop
communication skills that I wouldn't
have had otherwise were I not
contributing to open source uh and this
paper is uh fairly well received um it's
a fairly large project this one uh and
again all of it because I dove into
something and then got a little burned
by diving in head first into open source
and then decided to take a step back and
kind of sit at the pool see what's going
on and then once I figure out what's
going on start moving in from
there um
and just to to Really showcase how not
technical I am this is by
GitHub I you couldn't really tell I
contribute to any any projects here it's
mostly the gridcoin stuff uh but I I
have no commits no contributions but I
am a core contributor to multiple
projects uh these three being some
there's actually another one
here that I didn't bring up but this is
an open- source project still obviously
dealing with science but is also a
startup so it has brought me into the VC
world into the corporate world they're
they're trying to build
technology um and I get to build
communic uh communication channels go to
market
strategies um open source community that
sort of thing um all because a long long
time ago I found these guys I had a
passion I found a project that aligned
with with that passion and I started
contributing to that project um
definitely way too strong at the
beginning learned about how strong I
should probably be contributing to it
learned a lot about the open source
project the methodology of Open Source
and then started accelerating how I
contributed
um outside of these projects you know
there's first of all distributed
computing is a giant um ecosystem it's a
giant community in itself uh the the the
cryptocurrency ecosystem is massive and
a lot of it is garbage so I'll be the
first one to tell you that but there's
also some really cool projects there the
what's called dside Community is very
young but also amazing there are some um
uh very
neat uh connections and Partnerships
being built with some leading journals
and corporations and and companies uh
who are looking to use new technology to
enable able open science um and because
I'm a contributor to these open source
projects and not necessarily be Holden
to a company or Corporation I'm able to
choose where I spend my time and part of
that time is spent um organizing the D
larger DSi community so I'm organizing
uh an event right now actually in in
Colorado in Denver that will be taking
place in the end of February we just had
an event that I helped organize called D
Boston where we bring a lot of people
together and and have them talk about
new technologies and open science
um yeah and and so it's just a very
powerful way to contribute to again
something that I want to contribute to
not something I'm being told to
contribute to and by having that passion
first and then that desire to upskill
andn learn new things and then get paid
for those things second um I I'm able to
find the right places to go to start
getting paid for my time and num focus
is a great example of that I am so happy
and so proud to be someone who's
contributing to num Focus who's used all
the uh the skills I've learned over
these years through open source just
contributing randomly to stuff I enjoy
and getting paid along the way in random
bits and Bobs um but now being able to
contribute to a large nonprofit
organization that's supports a giant um
sphere of Open Source research projects
um it it's just it's a great feeling to
be able to do that and I question if I
had there's two things that would have
stopped me from being in the place I am
right now one was jumping in head first
and then getting kind of um Whiplash
from that or or yeah just like it's like
you're getting a car accident you
accelerate really quick and then you
stop so if I had stopped right after
that I would not be where I am right now
um
um yeah I forget the second one that's
really the big one uh if if I was not
contributing to a passion I wanted to do
I would have uh probably not been where
I was because there's burnout there's a
lot of burnout there's a lot
of um no part of the Whiplash is uh
noise in open source communities that
isn't
always uh it's not something you want to
do right and you don't have a boss you
don't have an HR department you can go
hey this person's just kind of being
mean or I don't know how to deal with
this person um a lot of communities now
have code of conducts which were not
super popular when I was starting an
open source um and they have code of
conduct committees and there's there's
starting to be ways to deal with that
sort of social Dynamic but
um having I think the easiest way to
deal with it is being contributing to
something you're passionate about you
you super you want to do regardless of
what's going on in the
background
um yeah so that that's essentially all I
have to talk about is my journey through
open source
um the the jumping first into a pool and
then kind of testing the waters and then
kind of just coming to terms with the
fact that hey you should
probably sit at the edge of the
pool well you know what you do what you
do you do your own way but I think a
good way to do it is to sit at the edge
of the pool and really look around and
see everyone else that's in the pool see
what projects exist that you might want
to contribute to based on your passion
and based on nothing else and then once
you find a couple projects that are
based on your passion then start to
bring in the other stuff all right which
one of these projects is going to let me
work in a field that I or or doing
something that I really want to do which
one of these projects is going to have
things for me to do that I don't know
how to do yet um and want to learn how
to do and we'll have someone there to
help teach me uh along the
way um if you do these things I think
you'll be able to find projects uh that
you can stick with for years and years
and you can find people within those
projects uh that you can end up building
some really cool stuff with this um move
this out of the way the the sci we're
not big we're not uh out there getting
massive donations but there's seven
super p of people all with our own jobs
outside of it who uh would have never
met if we didn't find a passion through
this original open- source project and
then just continue forming relationship
together so I don't know if there's any
questions or anything maybe I should
expand
on um I'm happy to talk about anything
or answer any questions if people are
new to open source
um or or just looking for anything I got
thoughts about most stuff I'll talk
about the weather if you
want um yeah can I just say thank you
for the talk um so it's it's it's quite
interesting the you know what you
explained as as your journey um and it
it just made me think about um you know
when I decided to get or switch career
into into Tech OT at the beginning of
that Journey uh I know I'm learning
about open source and the first thing
that comes to mind is right I need to to
learn to code and then contribute code
um and that's that's my thought process
a lot of people probably have the same
thought process uh but it's quite
different what you the route that you
took so what what led you to take that
route rather than the code in or the
technical uh
yeah that's a great question I tried to
learn to code so many times it's just
not in my blood
um and it was such a relief to me to
find out that these projects need help
outside of coding because I I'll I'll
try and I'm still trying like I'll still
Tinker like I said with GPT I'll have an
idea and I'll try to get something to
work and I've gotten things to work and
then um you know it's like one file of
just like this massive code block and I
would be so embarrassed to shut that
down but uh
yeah it's it's not what I want to do and
it there's a lot of um people like me I
think that don't want to code but also
want to contribute to a lot of these
projects that are so impactful in the
world around them and for the longest
time um you had to learn to code and it
it was a there was so much talent so
much mindpower that just went into a
different industry because they didn't
feel like there was a place for them to
contribute in open source projects so I
I was very lucky and that I found a
project where there was a need for
community building and kind of a desire
for it and it was built around a
technology that was also kind of social
at its core this distributed computing
the the boink platform has gamification
to it so there's teams and there's
competitions already um there just
wasn't a ton of Central Community around
it
um yeah that so short
answer I don't like
coding no I mean you know it's it's like
he said some or a lot most of these
projects do need uh people that deal
with the project aspect of it the
community aspect so um yeah definitely
uh do need different type of people and
different type of skills
um yeah and it's interesting too because
you you make me think of the phrase I
don't know if this is still used but
GitHub is your resume um I'm pretty sure
there were several talks today about how
you know the upscaling the gith you
contribute a GitHub until you build up a
backlog of contributions then you can
use that to go get a job somewhere
um that requires coding for a lot of it
because if get GitHub is only just
starting to incorporate project
management um tooling and and ways to
show off that you're contributing
projects that aren't code based uh so
being able
to keep track of and get a reputation in
open source without coding without
having that thousand commits or 10,000
lines of codes behind you uh was a huge
challenge which I hope is going to stop
be a challenge soon uh and another thing
I hope is that you can actually build up
a resume in open source software
starting from when you're really young
and never have to leave open Source you
can stay there and get paid you can find
the grants easily you can get sponsored
as a freelance developer or freelance
contributor by Microsoft or Google or
Facebook or one of the big corporations
that that usually takes people under
their under their wing um and stick
around and sell some of your time to
help someone else in something you might
not be super passionate about in order
to buy some of your own time back to
contribute continue contributing to
something super passionate about so
it's yeah I don't know necessarily where
I was going about with uh going with
going there but there's a there's a lot
of potential with contributing to open
source with sticking in the ecosystem
and the people you meet and sticking
with them and not necessarily leaving
just because there's a you know five or
six figure job waiting for you outside
of
it yeah I think one one key takeway from
from your talk and You' said it many
many times is is Passion find something
you're passionate about um that's
definitely something that that will stay
my
mind so yeah thanks for
that definitely absolutely it's
a thanks for the question engagement if
anyone else wants to chat feel
free it's um there's so in science this
is a little bit of a tangent but in
science there's a lot of brilliant
people that get into science
which is absolutely brilliant they're
great at math they're great at uh
problem solving they're great at um um
conflict resolution critical thinking
and they then go to university and they
homeone these skills and they learn the
complimentary skills and then they get
their degree whatever degree it is they
realize oh my only like 1% of phds get
hired go on a tenure track or something
like that there's not a lot of positions
for them and so they get sucked up this
brain power gets sucked up by another
sector or some other sector and usually
I don't know if it's usually a lot of
the time is the financial sector and
they become like Quant stock
Traders like the the dream is that no
you can you can go to open source yeah
it would be amazing to be up a 10-year
Professor but no start contributing to
an open source project contribute to
numpy contribute to any other project
out there and get paid for it so you
don't need to go be a banker
you can still contribute to society with
your passion because you see a lot of
these people then get super jaded about
everything they learned about all
academic system and I could ramble on
forever but open source is a great
escape hatch for that sort of
thing I see a a hand up
um go ahead hi this is a here actually I
had a question for you like uh I have
seen many rules like you said that you
don't code but you you got in a tech job
so what is a like job like if you don't
qu then how you got a job in Tech like
you're are a community manager or you
are a developer Advocate like what is
your job like we can also get some ideas
as I'm I'm also not that good in coding
and I'm also looking for a job I know
Python and
SQL so um I'm a program manager uh which
means I work a high level strategy and
then how we Implement that strategy
towards a goal so I'll work with the
rest of the no Focus team to find well
the OSI team to to Define our goals
figure out how we're going to get there
and then figure out the small steps to
get to those goals in the end um that's
something I love to do I love to
organize and plan and then execute on
plan uh incredibly nerdy about that uh
other ways I've seen people contribute
uh there's a huge lack of design cap
ability in a lot of these projects like
logos communication resources um U
websites uh they're incredibly technical
they're they're built for a a builder
they're built for a developer and not a
user so someone who doesn't who isn't
part of the community and doesn't
already know what this software is will
come in and look at this website and be
like overwhelmed and just leave because
they have no idea what to do um which is
one of the things OSI is trying to do is
trying to bring a researcher who might
not know what some of these tools are
and and connect them to developers of
the tools so that um the developers can
build more userfriendly
tools um so design web design user
experience design
um developer advocacy the two you
mentioned were
good um writing copywriting so that
white paper I showed you um is a great
one
uh and there're also really easy ways to
start getting involved in some of these
projects because almost every project
has the need for someone to help with
writing something or editing
something
um and then Community Management is is a
big one because a lot of these open
source communities whether you're the
like Community manager a co-manager or
just someone who runs a um sort of like
an event once a week a podcast or a
gaming night or something like something
like that these open source projects are
built on community that's their their
whole thing the whole stick of Open
Source is community not Corporation so
if um company a is building software
they're going to build that software and
and they don't really necessarily care
who's building it if one person leaves
the company they'll hire someone else
and they'll build the software with
these open source projects some of these
people are so they know the projects
that they're like part of the code
themselves um but they're not Community
people they don't want to build a
community but they still need that
Community to help build to so they're
not the only person who knows the God so
that there's someone else there to help
manage and maintain um that that is a
huge need in the space as Community
organizers okay thank you so much
absolutely I'm so happy that someone
here is wanting to get involved in open
source and not on the co side that's
very exciting
is everyone else here on the software
development
side or is there anyone else here who's
not a software developer also see thumbs
up I'd be curious Jose do you already
contribute to a
project uh no I do not contribute to any
project right
now um are you do you want to well I I
honestly I have never considered it but
um uh I need to look into it like you
said find a
project that I'm passionate about I
don't know what's out there really but I
need to start looking into
it yeah even like take a step further
back find a a field you're passionate
about and then see if there a project in
that field so maybe you like AI find an
open source project on AI maybe like 3D
rendering find an open source project on
3D rendering Maybe really like finding
prime numbers I know there's a lot of
Open Source projects that look for prime
numbers to do some really geeky mous
stuff which is super fascinated but not
in my wheelhouse
um yeah you should you should definitely
look into it I'm glad you're here
then great place to learn yeah
definitely will thank
you also Vermont great place for open
source
and I love it maybe maybe a little bit
too cold for me but yeah it's it's a
beautiful
state I was just gonna um jump in this
as as well um there's a lot of like NOS
that are um or think tanks that are like
open to like voluntary contribution on
the gith hubs and whatnot and uh often
times I was going to say like even if
you just don't contribute to like a
tooling like I I don't contribute to
tools but like um I kind of
like I'm like part-timing for a think
time uh which like I'm the main research
associate but like we work with other uh
NGO thing tanks and then uh we we share
like our
yeah this I've never heard of these
actually do you have any resources for
that I would love to look into
it uh not particularly open source but
uh there there's a few like
op open source like uh NGO for example
uh I used to uh code contribute for like
humanitarian open street map so they do
um disaster mapping for uh for uh for
like they deliver disaster map for like
uh
Doctors Without Borders and whatnot when
when earthquake happens and um and then
also contribute for like food security
uh Think Tank and uh yeah I could send a
few out uh but um yeah I and oftentimes
I when I used to work in startups
sometimes the NGO also attract really
really senior developers so you they
actually have like a much much higher
standard Tech stack than some cppy
startup interesting yeah that's awesome
it makes me think of like projects that
are citizen science like folding at home
or um fold it like games that aren't
necessarily software but anyone can
contribute to and I think we're running
short on time so I won't go off a
tangent on
that